[Music]
English lessons today's mini English
lesson is all about speculation ever
dreamt of being a detective to be a good
detective you need to use modal verbs to
speculate about the past today's case
who stole the orange from the green
grocer now if you want to be a good
detective
you could speculate about the past using
maybe or perhaps but if you want to be a
great English detective you're going to
use modal verbs they sound more natural
we're not going to use all the modal
verbs we're just going to select a few
the ones we're gonna keep a count might
must may could and couldn't
now these describe differing degrees of
probability about who sold the orange it
reminds have been the boy just next to
the green grocer it could have been the
brother of the green grocer he's always
looked a bit shifty it may have been the
old lady with a very big bag it can't be
initially look at her she's angelic and
she's holding the camera it couldn't be
me I'm innocent
I know it must have been the white of
the green grocer look at her she's
licking her lips and I can see orange
peel all around her when we say it must
have been her we're saying we're about
95 percent sure it was her we've got
some evidence the orange peel when we
said couldn't be me or it can't be
Mishler we're 95% sure it wasn't us but
when we say it might be a little boy it
may have been a girl it could have been
the brother we're not really sure we
don't have any evidence either way let's
say we're 50% sure so you can see that
we use these modal verbs to speculate
past how probable we think something was
but we're not speculating about the
present we're speculating that past so
we need to use a very specific formula
to do that we need to take the local
verb put it here then we need to take a
cab it's always half it doesn't change
but it here and finally we need the past
participant you know steel so stolen so
when we have this for me like he must
have stolen and the orange you can see
we've got a shining example of deduction
speculation about the past when you put
all that together nobody will know
you're anything but the greatest
detective ever Elementary really
[Music]